zayats vitals car tester sanic nap
explains that Fiat and Chrysler have
been cooperating since 2009 Lancia is a
Fiat brand to product of this alliance
of the Lancia Thema and the Lancia
Voyager now it's third is the Lancia
Flavia convertible based on the Chrysler
200 convertible that convertible the
flavia's exterior appears well done an
elegant light catching contour runs the
entire 4 meter 0.95 length
LED headlights are standard equipment
a beefy grill gives the car a touch of
assertiveness the first glance the
flavia's rear looks a bit wide LED
taillights are also standard the Lancia
flavia's powerhouse is a 2.4 litre 125
kilowatt gasoline engine with a maximum
speed of 195 km/h fuel consumption is
rated at nine point four liters 400
kilometers nobody's idea of ecological
Sasha says to make matters worse the
small engine is combined with a rather
unsuitable automatic transmission so
when you step on the gas but you hardly
notice any increase in speeds it manages
0 to 100 kilometres an hour in 11
seconds the only engine that flavia
comes with is not that much fun to drive
but on the bright side the six and a
half inch screen for the GPS CD and DVD
drive the USB port a Bluetooth
speakerphone and cruise control are all
standard equipment
at first glance that anti-air flavia's
interior also looks quite well done an
analog clock in the center console gives
it a classic Flair
it's overdone flap Sasha says once the
top is opened up the back seats are
quite comfortable but then if you've got
four basketball players in the car it
doesn't work out quite as well however
for him
it's very there Latasha theists a Lancia
flavia's rear is enormous the tailgate
is very heavy and underneath is the
converted of trike the cargo space only
has a volume of 198 litres when the top
is up a total 477 litres of space can be
used optically the Flavio works but the
weak engine is on - starting price of
37,000 700 euros in Germany makes it
attractive to convertible fans